je vous aime vous m'aimez aimons nos
jambes ou dès qu'on vient d'entendre
michel coulomb bonsoir à vous le mans et
vous l'aimiez beaucoup vous avez écrit
avec lui un livre deschamps livre
d'entretiens parce qu'il voulait parler
de son métier je voulait l'entendre et
ça a été un grand plaisir
bon si on commence par le début c'est
gilles martin photographe qui le révèle
effectivement il y à 42 ans il nous
représente est en compétition au
festival de cannes il représentait le
canada rappelant que monique mercure en
est revenu avec le prix d'interprétation
féminine
une réflexion moderne étonnante sur le
couple est une co écrit avec marcel
sabourin interpréter et sur par marcel
sabourin et monique mercure
une réflexion qui présentait un couple
du passé mais des dégrés des rapports
hommes femmes qui étaient tous que plus
contemporain c'est à dire des années 70
la place de la femme dans le couple le
partage des responsabilités
il va travailler elle reste à la maison
un jour elle dit c'est assez c'est la
rose aimée volcanique de monique mercure
un rôle absolument formidable un travail
sur la lumière ans était lui même
photographe au départ il n'était pas
être jusqu'à la fin de sa vie donc c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait ce travail
plastique et ça paraît dans son travail
pierre mignot sur ce film j'ai un martin
photographe modèle mercure vous êtes qui
a gagné la palme d'or d'interprétation
qui n'était pas accable d'ailleurs qu'il
n'a pas reçues on n'a pas voulu lui dire
donc elle était sur la scène du tnm
parce que quelqu'un pour lui la prévenir
at un bon passage il ya eu d'autres
films on va reparler mais l'autre coup
d'éclat c'est les filles de caleb où
c'est la série la plus populaire de
l'histoire la télévision québécoise 4
millions de personnes qui étaient émus à
chaque semaine 2 à ça et pour cause
scénario de fernand dansereau roman dans
l'imposture interprétation formidable
mais réalisation solide puissante
extraordinaire de jean beaudin qui
prenait pour la première fois une série
entière il avait travaillé alors ils
papier mais là effectivement il a montré
son travail de plasticien son travail de
compteurs son amour des comédiens c'est
quelque chose qui le portait tout au
long de sa carrière
nathalie mallette dans rue dupuis marina
orsini tous ces acteurs sont formidables
et ce récit qui nous
rejoignez encore là il parlait du passé
et ça nous rejoignait au présent il
avait cet art effectivement d'une forme
de métaphore historique qui n'était pas
que passéiste il y avait dans ses
personnages quelque chose qui nous
rejoignait et ne définissait
complètement et c'était pas un sous
produit parce que c'était à la
télévision c'était une série donc bien
assumé oui cinématographique des
premiers réalisateurs avec jean claude
laur à assumer ce passage du cinéma vers
la télévision se disant que ce n'était
pas une disgrâce que de passer d'un
genre à l'autre aujourd'hui ça paraît
naturel à l'époque en 1990 se l'était
déjà beaucoup moins rôles interdit
aujourd'hui ils étaient découvreur de
talents oui parce qu'il aimait les
acteurs donc il a créé ce que
j'appellerais me déroule signature en
scène guillaume lemay thivierge vous
pensez tout de suite aux matous louise
portal vous pensez à cordelia rodge puis
et marina orsini vous pensez aux filles
de caleb notamment mais vous pensez
beaucoup filles de caleb et marina
orsini dans cette série était énergique
lumineuse terre à terre et ô combien
touchante
il avait vu ça chez elle on avait déjà
vu bien sûr la télévision il avait trahi
lesquels pour l'heure il papier il a
fait d'elle ce personnage extraordinaire
qu'on a aimé suivre semaine après
semaine formidable mariners animé fusion
vraiment deux des comédiens avec le
réalisateur
d'ailleurs on essaie de parler mariners
signé dès qu'on l'a allez on va on voit
bien sûr lui parler mais en attendant
écoutons jean bodin nous parler de cet
amour qu'il avait des comédiens
travailler avec un acteur ou une actrice
il ya une grande échange de ces chants
les plus profondes que tu peux avoir en
tant pis c'est presque le plus je suis
exigeant plus je pense que les comédiens
ça les rassure c'est une façon de dire
je vous aime vous mais baby aimons nous
bon alors si on peut lui parler on lui
parlera marina mais ça a changé sa vie
oui évidemment oui parce que bon déjà on
avait vu dans ses comptes mais là cette
femme extraordinaire c'est emilie
bordeloo à laquelle on s'est vraiment
identifie attachés et la série repasse à
la télé bein c'est à nouveau un succès
mais ça s'arrête pas là le travail de
jean beaudin si poursuivi avec chéri par
exemple dans le cas de marina orsini
pour la télévision miséricorde bien sûr
aussi ses enfants d'ailleurs mais au
cinéma ça donne aussi being at home with
claude kross lui a décru dupuis a pris
un rôle qui n'était pas fait sur mesure
pour rue du puits parce que c'est
lothaire bluteau qu'il avait créée au
théâtre un physique plus gracile le roy
dupuis qui avait bon un côté quand même
un peu plus macho il l'a complètement
réinventé si on peut dire transformer
son physique effet dans ce duo de jean
godin airs du puits un échange mais
extraordinaire qui était celui de la
pièce grenadine daniel dubois un homme
qui a tué et qui se confesse lentement
au fil d'une nuit mais d'autres films
bien sûr mario rappelez-vous de francis
résidents marion le chum fait aux îles
de la madeleine il a aussi tourné sans
aide cet endroit là est donc une série
de films comme ça qui ont marqué
l'imaginaire il arrivait bien à
transposer soir omar les coups sûrs dont
a parlé soit bientôt huis clos d'une
pièce de théâtre
il transpose est bien ou cinéma il avait
ce talent il s'appropriait et en
travaillant avec des scénaristes
alors que plein de réalisateur de
nombreux réalisateurs québécois étaient
plutôt effrayer face à la littérature
voulait pas aller là voulais raconter
leur histoire lui prenait effectivement
le roman d'yves beauchemin un roman de
chrystine brouillette de monique proulx
le travail de rené daniel dubois donc de
tous ces auteurs arlette cousture bien
sûr au premier chef
il prenait ses oeuvres là ils se les
appropriant il se disait pas ce sera
moins bien
il voulait partager ses histoires et
ensuite il faisait son travail à lui
c'est à dire un travail de cinéma
cinémas pour le cinéma comme pour la
télévision à sa vie ensemble s'avère un
travail d'image travail de mise en scène
le travail de direction d'acteurs donc
vous le placez michel parmi les grandes
c'est un directeur qui a marqué le
cinéma québécois notamment parce qu'il
est un des premiers sinon vraiment un
des premiers peut-être que jean claude
laur encore
à s'être tout de suite dit je ne veux
pas faire de documentaires c'est à dire
que les réalisateurs québécois ceux de
la régénération denys arcand qui est de
sa génération qui était un ami ont
commencé en documentaire émigrés
tranquillement vers la fiction
une fiction qui étaient influencés par
leur pratique du réel lui bon afin de
petites expériences à louannec à ses
débuts des films scientifiques là mais
rapidement il a voulu faire du cinéma de
fiction ça peut marcher
au tout début ensuite il revenu à des
cours moyens métrages et là c'est lent
c'est effectivement avec jaime martin
photographe avec le succès qu'on c'est à
partir de là ça ne s'est pas démentie
donc ce choix de la fiction il a ouvert
la voie plein d'autres comme son choix
de passer indifféremment et avec grand
talent du cinéma à la télévision au
cinéma si ça lui tentait deux choses
avant de vous quitter
il voulait et on a vu les images de ce
prix qui a reçu en 2010 est à ottawa il
voulait faire un dernier film il aurait
voulu faire un autre film sur les images
qu'on voit il boxe sur une petite vidéo
qu'il a fait en dix ans je suis prêt à
remonter sur le ring il s'était retiré
après les échecs de nouvelle france et
sans elle qu'il avait un dur ce qui
l'avait meurtri dévastée oui il n'y
arrivait pas vu l'ex planque c'était
vraiment retirer de la profession il
l'ignorait quand il a reçu ses prix donc
ce prix spécifiquement celui du
gouverneur général
et puis ensuite qu'il était atteint de
la maladie de parkinson
donc il l'a appris tout de suite après
mais au moment où ils témoignent ils
pensent encore qu'il est possible de
faire un retour parce qu'il a une
histoire à raconter voulez parler de
deux mini black il dit plusieurs fois
qui était sa compagne une période de sa
vie il avait beaucoup aimé une
comédienne laquelle il a travaillé qui
était décédé il écrivait était un
scénario autour d'elle donc il voulait
revenir en force pas quittée sur quelque
chose qui avait laissé une mauvaise
image de lui ses échecs là
des derniers films l'avait effectivement
meurtri d'accord alors michel si on veut
revoir pour les plus jeunes qui nous
écoute d'abord gilles martin photographe
avoir autant indispensable indispensable
quand délia bien sûr vous verrez une
louise portal vraiment étonnante tout
jeune dans ce rôle terrible oui georges
encore une histoire qui était racontée
avec marcel sabourin qui était co
scénariste pourriez voir la syrie willy
qu'il a réalisé aussi avec le guen un
rôle de willie lamothe pourriez voir
effectivement being at home with claude
qui est un film extrêmement maîtrisé
brillamment réalisé mario si vous voulez
rêver puis vous rendre aux îles de la
madeleine
bref une filmographie cinéma télévision
extrêmement riche et qui nous appartient
toujours ça fait partie de notre
patrimoine il faut dire merci à jean
beaudin merci avant michel coulomb mon
plaisir